That's the rat with a pizza. I've seen
that. Oh yeah, the pizza rat. That's,
he's famous. Rats are disgusting
too. Yeah, they're pretty gross.
Have you ever seen that Netflix
documentary on rats? Yeah. No. Oh.
Oh No. Really? Oh Dude. Really? Yeah.
You need to watch it because it's,
um, it's educational. It's not
just gross and it's really gross.
But when you realize how many of them
that really are in major cities. Yeah.
The bio mass of them. Yeah.
It's a fuck stunning. Really.
York's all rat. Just
rats. This is many rat.
It's more or somewhere in the neighborhood
of as many rats as there are people
really.
And there's 8 million people and there's
how many more as or more she's just,
I mean, you see them nonstop walking
around. I'm just guessing. Yeah.
Obviously most of them are subterranean.
Most of them are living in houses.
And most of them, I mean, they burrow
their way into tiny little holes.
How long does the rat live to question?
How long does the rat live?
Because they're born,
there's a lot of them,
but do they stick around for like 20
years to the documentary showed how they
send young rats to try out
poison. Oh really? Yeah.
The old suicide rats, they send them out
there cause they don't know any better.
They let them die. They're just assholes.
Wow. Yeah. They, here's a little tip,
if they're ever doing construction
in New York in front of a restaurant,
you don't eat it. You don't
need on that street. Why?
Because they're digging it up.
Whatever their little ecosystem
is and they're just cool. Yeah.
So if they're digging up the street,
they're dying somewhere else.
I would imagine in New York and must be
so hard to keep them out of a restaurant.
Oh, it's gotta be so hard. I guess maybe
leave some in the dumpster for him.
Like you give a leg to a
monsters. Just the head. Yeah.
Like when they used to tie the
girl into the, the stakes for Kong.
So you'd leave everybody else alone.
I did a little shish Kebab stick.
It's like your last job too.
When you're closing down the restaurant,
you pull the gates down.
Are Our friend put the skulls out?
Well, what is interesting? What
are those various sizes of them?
They mostly go up to about
two pounds in New York City.
He doesn't think there's any that are
three because they'd be too big to be able
to move around. Right. Like a physical
or physiological limit to their size.
Does it say how long they
live? Average? About two years.
One to two years in the wild, up to four.
If you have it as a pet, a wow. That's,
it could have hamsters.
I like that.
My wife had rats for pets when
she was a kid. Was she Goff now?
She was just like Jersey kid.
Just loved animals and she would just
ride her bike around in this rat would
just be like on her shoulders.
Jesus Christ. Drat lady. Weird.
Yeah. It's weird. I get it
if it's here, but it was,
but she said they were super
smart and super affectionate.
If you had his whole life and you
raise it right? Yeah. Why not? Yeah.
It's not dirty.
It's not like going through the sewers
and eating poo and climate in your hand.
Right. But it would,
if you just let it go,
maybe 100% she like had
it out with her go rat.
Like if you just let it let it loose in
the wild. How long would it take for?
How long would it take for a domesticated
rat to adapt to living in like a New
York City sewer? 40 seconds.
What do you think they were?
Do they just get their crazy fucking
Disney movie from the suburbs when he'd
been living in a house? Yeah,
with like multicolored rats.
They have like all these little
different colors on them. Oh,
you so clean with your pink hair.
Oh, you can different colors. Look,
hey Joe, get a load of this
one. He's not even Greg. Hey,
how come you ain't Greg? Look at
you. You're white. You're brown.
You're like a fucking dog over there.
Thank you. Better than us, don't ya? Hey,
get over here. I guess you don't
know how to get into the restaurant.
What do you got money on you?
You give us some money,
we'll show you where you get all the
good food. Yeah. You ever been a little,
literally wait til I show
you what? It's a show.
Rolling dice. Getting born. A rap.
Being born a rat. Oh. Oh, ugh.
The worst.
Terrible.